Welcome back everyone this is the way Jedi
Survivor just came out a lot of you've been
asking when Cal kestis will show up in the
live-action Star Wars series in the new movies
so we'll break it all down because there is
a plan to do calcastus in live action they
even just posted this clip of him training
with Luke Skywalker remember just feel it
all right you're on Koboh the MoGo Wampa thing
is coming you're not scared show me focus good
I'm not playing baseball right you will take me to
the senator now take me to the center let's risk
all good you get two lightsabers well
technically one but I can split them
never gave me two lightsabers if you're brand new
to the channel there's a whole bunch of Star Wars
coming up this year I'll be doing Ahsoka episode
videos just like the Mandalorian and it's getting
started this summer be sure to subscribe to get
everything it is going to be amazing there's a
lot of really cool stuff coming up if you don't
have any experience with the Cal Kestis video
games he's played by Cameron Monahan who has
a lot of live-action acting experience most of
you probably remember him is Jerome from Gotham
which was as close as they were allowed to get
to the Joker character so he kind of played a
younger version The Joker but isn't a lot of
other Prestige series and movies outside of Star
Wars so he is a legit actor and one of the big
things in the Star Wars Universe Dave filoni
has been slowly bringing all these animated
actors who do have live action experience to
do the live-action versions of their characters
they haven't returned dispatch in weeks
they're swamped and never get an answer
in time Boca tan Crees Katie sakhoff one of the
best examples that as is Grand Admiral thrawn
who's going to be played by Lars Mickelson who
did the voice during Star Wars Rebels Cameron
Monahan's calcestus is just the next example of
that like really good actor who just happens to
be playing a character that's not in live action
yet the characters the protagonist of Jedi Fallen
order Jedi Survivor and there will be a third
game they did reveal it's going to be a Trilogy
of games that won't be released for about four
more years 2027 at the rate they're going each
one moving his timeline forward by a couple years
with the characters that are parts of those he
was a Padawan before Order 66 whose original
Jedi Master was jarrow to Paul he's al-assad
just like Zeb who we saw in live action on the
Mandalorian from Star Wars Rebels he'll also be
on the Ahsoka series as well too because of doing
all live-action versions of the Ghost characters
good luck you're gonna need it so you have
to imagine his Jedi Master look just like Zeb
swinging around a lightsaber his lightsaber that
he uses in all the games is actually his master's
lightsaber that he's just modified originally he
survived Order 66 and continues to survive Darth
Vader and the inquisitors through the events of
his games and without getting into huge spoilers
for the events of Jedi Survivor because it just
came out people probably still playing the game
his story arc in the games is slowly learning how
to resist the Empire and fight them effectively
fight Darth Vader the inquisitors and help the
other Jedi survivors who survived the purge Order
66 as well as new Force sensitive people that are
trying to use the hidden path to survive them as
well if you remember the hidden path is basically
like the Underground Railroad in the Galaxy like a
galactic Underground Railroad that was a big plot
point during the Obi-Wan Kenobi Series where you
have other Jedi survivors from Order 66 that are
helping other Force sensitives escape the empire
what is this place some call it the path
you're not the first Jedi to come through
here still got a lot of work ahead of us
it will take time to contact the hidden path
and find the anchor rights and build a saloon
the events of Jedi Survivor also take place 10
years after revenge of this which is exactly
the same year that Obi-Wan Kenobi series took
place Obi-Wan Kenobi which is mostly in the
mid-rim territories and for most of the events of
Jedi Survivor calcas is way over here closer to
the unknown regions on the far left part of the
Galaxy the very first part of the game does take
place on Coruscant but then most of it takes place
over here on Kobo and tanalore so that's why you
didn't see him on Obi-Wan Kenobi just because
he's in a different part of the Galaxy for the
most part based on his age right now calcasus is
only a little bit younger than Ahsoka she's in her
mid-40s during the events of the Mandalorian
series like she's a little bit older than the
Mando she and Boca tan are pretty close to the
same age but we call that part of the timeline
the Mando verse because all the shows in that
part of the timeline are meant to be connected
and cross over with each other leading up to
that thrawn movie heir to the Empire in real
life Cameron Monahan is only about 29 years old
but that's not a huge deal like putting a little
old age wear and tear on his face like some City
miles on his face with light makeup is pretty easy
they don't even need to spend money on CG to add a
few years to his face also there's a lot of Series
right now taking place earlier in the timeline
when he'd be younger like the Andor Series in
the Obi-Wan Kenobi series which they talked about
doing Obi-Wan Kenobi season 2. the main reason
why you haven't seen him in any of the live-action
Star Wars series or movies yet is mostly just for
story based reasons relative to what's happening
with his games Dave filoni John Favreau the other
Star Wars people making those shows into the parts
of the timeline like Tony Gilroy who's doing the
Andor series that's not meant to be connected
to the mandover so like Tony Gilroy doesn't work
with Dave filoni and John Favreau the reason why
they're not using Cal Kestis yet is because Star
Wars has a bigger plan to let calcisus finish
his story of the trilogy of his games in that
earlier part of the timeline before they use him
later in the timeline during the Mandalorian the
Ahsoka series any of the other potential spin-off
series that they'll do in the future because of
course Ahsoka would learn about Cal Kestis through
the hidden path she helps support the hidden path
and worked with the rebels using the code named
fulcrum during the rise of the empire in that
part of the timeline before A New Hope through
the events of the Andor series she served as
sort of the point of communication between all
these disparate Rebel cells so she knew pretty
much most of what was going on around the Galaxy
during that period in Cal Kestis most recently is
beginning to work as a major part of the Hidden
path in the other Jedi survivors for sensitives
that are trying to escape the Empire by using the
tanalor planet eventually later in the timeline
when the Rebellion did come together formally
and they became this giant fighting force before
the original trilogy he'd be helping them too the
reason why you haven't really heard about calcasus
till now through all this Canon is just because
they only recently created the character it's the
exact same Phenomenon with the Ahsoka character
she's not mentioned in the prequels by name
because George Lucas and Dave filoni didn't create
the Ahsoka character till after Revenge of the
Sith had been released in theaters so they wound
up using the Clone Wars to explain what Ahsoka
had been doing with Anakin Skywalker during the
events of the prequels same thing with calcastes
through the different parts of the timeline itches
is that most of the people that are making these
new movies the Star Wars series are waiting till
Cal kessus's third game comes out so they don't
wind up spoiling what happens in that third game
but they do heavily imply what's going on with
this character what his plans are for the future
and like I said based on the release schedule for
these Cal Kestis games the third game might not
come out till 2027 if they hold to that four-year
plan between games which would also put it during
the same year as that Mandalorian thrawn movie I
just did a much longer video explaining the thrawn
heir to the Empire movie plans so I'll add a link
for that in the description below but right now
Star Wars plan for these new movies that they
just announced there are three new movies they
just announced is for the new sequel movie set
15 years after the rise of Skywalker to release
in 2025 that'll be the first new Star Wars movie
then release Dave filoni's thrawn movie within
two years of that then James mangold's dawn of
the Jedi movie after that now the schedule could
shift around a little bit and they release some
stuff a little bit sooner but that's the planned
release order for the new movies and the really
cool thing for the people that are really hyped
up about Grand Admiral thrawn and live action
they did say that they didn't announce trilogies
for each of these different parts of the timeline
just because they're waiting to see how these
first movies do so there is a solid chance that
we could get a thrawn Trilogy of movies and while
all those Mandalorian era movies are happening
John Favreau revealed that they do have plans to
continue making shows in that part of the timeline
they have a solid 20 years worth of timeline at
this point to explore the Mando verse of shows so
like the Mandalorian won't go for 20 Seasons but
there'll be other spin-offs like the Ahsoka series
and other future spin-offs that they haven't
announced yet that will take place in that part of
the timeline after the events of when these other
shows like the Mandalorian winds up ending its
run so like grogu's story will continue throughout
all those different spin-offs ahsoka's story will
continue even though all the shows won't each get
20 Seasons the other upcoming show that they just
announced the Star Wars Skeleton Crew series is a
Mandalorian spin-off taking place relatively close
to where calcas is near the unknown regions in the
tanalor planet so just another example of series
that are taking place really close to where he is
where he could show up the other major thing that
the Star Wars people are using the calcestus
character for is to push the overall Star Wars
story in the story of the Jedi into completely new
territory new characters new locations and within
the calcestus trilogy of games there is enough
going on there are enough backstory enough room in
the story that they can just give Cal Kestis his
own live-action series like yes eventually cross
him over with the mandovers in that part of the
timeline eventually when he's a little bit older
but also just give him his own series earlier
in the timeline just because Cameron Monaghan is
still so young in real life they can do multiple
seasons of a calcasta series set before the events
of Andor or if they wait a little bit longer
they can also do it later after Return of the
Jedi as part of the Mandalorian spin-offs in
a different part of the Galaxy eventually Luke
Skywalker would learn about him when he began
actively seeking out Force sensitives to train
at his new Jedi Academy groku just happened to be
the first one that he found and during that part
of the timeline it's implied during Jedi survive
ever that calcasus's ultimate plan with Merrin
was to continue his relationship with her and
help other Jedi force senses find a place where
they could live out their lives they imply that
place is the tanalor planet just because of how
well defended it is the natural phenomena the
nebula destroying most ships that try to enter
it or find a path through it's the safest place in
the Galaxy for them to all stay hidden from Darth
Vader and the inquisitors aside from just being
lost in the unknown region somewhere there are
also a lot of other threats in the unknown
regions those are teasing that out through
Grandad both thrawn's story The chiss as well
as the grisk there's lots of stuff going on in
the unknown regions just in general is this very
new fertile story territory that Star Wars hasn't
explored yet so after the fall of the Empire it
just sounds like calcasus plans to train New Jedi
there on tanalore using the Jedi books to survive
they only have three books so it's kind of like
Luke Skywalker also trying to create a new Jedi
Order using limited materials that survived Order
66 but the whole idea is that all these different
figures like grogu Luke Skywalker calcas all have
very different idea is about how to pursue their
training in the force like grogu won't turn out
exactly like Yoda he'll be more like tar vizla
the first Mandalorian Jedi because he both became
a Mandalorian but he'll also continue training
in the force same thing with Cal Kestis who also
has Merrin a nightsister who uses the force in a
very different way who will be helping train New
Jedi his order would look completely different
than Luke Skywalker's Jedi Order so there is a
grand plan for the calcasa's character in live
action series and movies if everything works
out long term and we are talking about long term
in addition to crossing over with the other new
movies in series he would just get his own series
but remember that's still years and years away we
still have the next game in the trilogy in about
four years let me know in the comments where's the
first place you want to see Cal Kestis appear
in the live action series and movies would you
rather see him during future seasons of Ahsoka
the main Mandalorian series might be done after
the next four to five years but Ahsoka will go
a little past that and according to John Favreau
and Dave flony there will be other spin-offs
in that part of the timeline after Ahsoka and
the Mandalorian end there run one or would you
rather see a live-action calcasa series and have
other characters like Ahsoka and Luke Skywalker
Cameo during that we'll start getting more Ahsoka
trailer videos really soon so of course I'll do
videos for everything that they wind up releasing
they'll also probably release some cool stuff for
Star Wars day as well too there's a new season
of Star Wars Visions this happening so I'll try
to do some Star Wars Visions videos as well too
everyone click here for my Mandalorian season
4 teaser video and click here for my Ahsoka
trailer video in Easter eggs thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!